hello my name is Tracy Stewart and I'm
Jason wall and welcome to bloopers
blunders and bad lines the show where we
look at over games that we've played and
show you what not to do
let's take a look Shirley look at a game
that we played back from 2018 so I play
you were the white side and I was the
black side and you played efore at the
time I was playing the Scandinavian so I
played d5 and you decided to play e5
shoulda took the pot shoulda took the
pawn so take the pawn I take the Queen
and probably play wet Knight c3 here
yeah that's a that's a standard line
that I've always run into with the
Scandinavian but play e5 when I played
c5 so now I've got a decent kind of
French position ok night of 396 this
should be five depending the night to
the yep yeah I was just learning how to
move pieces so let's go alright Bishop
disowned trying to break the pin and h3
and here I could have played the move or
I play the movie six but there's a
blunder tip there's actually a free pawn
here for me and do you see it Tracy
that's right complain Knight take E 5
because if you play Bishop take E 5 I
can take back with the knight or if you
play if you take the pawn and I take the
knight all right I could take the bishop
either way either way I get a pawn and
out of this but but instead I played
east six just defending my defending my
phone there so d3 yd3 yeah that one
doesn't stand seems a little interesting
to me
probably or you're trying to free up
your bishop okay maybe bring it to chief
F for a bg5 both are common ideas but
you for Earth III excuse me
Knight ge7 trying to develop my piece
however I had the move that we show
later that was a blunder a mistake for
me
so Knight c3 d4 Knight e4 and now my
mistake I play Queen a5 beautiful what
do you play here Tracy alright I take
the bit and I take the bait why did you
take the bait there really wasn't much
else to play probably could have just
went back but now you've got you've got
a lot and I definitely I definitely
cannot go back to d8 because you have
some other night yeah yeah so so Bishop
d2 Queen's a p5 Bishop 96 nice for King
d8 Queen take be five or night a p5 but
the idea that I came up with with Queen
a5 actually works back here I'll move
sex
I can play Queen a5 right now because
now your knight is not protecting that
your knight is not developed developed
and I could play night you can play
Knight c3 to protect and block and I
completely deep I could play d4 then and
now you're a Knights not gonna be able
to go anywhere but I didn't so you took
the Queen and 96 which is probably what
I should have played instead of Queen
AIDS or queen e5 Knight g5
okay just if just undefended the pond
probably should've just cancelled maybe
on check take take
maybe check here I just probably
probably I don't I give up my bishop
hair probably probably just this night
back maybe um might see a seven either
won't be good but 96-95
undefended upon so I just aside I'll
take it with this night castles that's
why I took with that right castles now
it's hacking the bishop protect the
bishop attacking the knight you castle
and I just take the bishop for free but
I take the knife for free I'm looking at
this game's like yeah Casa cos that's
what yeah just give you all my pieces
take it all right so so Bishop f4 no
unfortunately hang another piece rookie
one f6 kicking the night away I'm taking
the night now it's the vulgar Queen so
now your walks are connected that's the
only good thing I'm in this right now
right now yeah
Castle yeah yeah lose two pieces and
then I mean yeah I've got three minors
I've got three minors you have three
heavies I've got the two rooks it's an
okay but so rook take you five or Brooke
take you say excuse me
basically we are no it's a free pawn
bishop ease Bishop c6.r oke one now
you're doubling on the file and you
control the e-file various very well
ninety-seven I put my notes that this is
is really strong because I attack the
night attack tonight then work out the
rook EPS yes I thank the rook and this
Bishop is now heading the Queen so you
have to give up one of these pieces so
I'm gonna gain an exchange back rook Eve
for Brooke see each c4 rook 64 excuse me
please some have fun I went back that's
why you went back because you're you're
gonna lose the you're gonna lose your
queen instead so you just give up your
rook for that which is fine I mean
probably yeah Rippey eight China trying
to reroute this night maybe to get out
to be six and start to be involved in
the game c3 take take now you've got
this isolated pawn I've got these three
these three and you have out that's what
that line not yet
so b6 connecting the pawns d4 trying to
shatter my pawns give me a check
Rick d1 I'm trying to bring yourself
into that battery Bishop c5 Queen d7 and
also actually developing my rook with
that Queen B eight or quick in b7 and a
four and a five and unfortunately you
ran into some time trouble and we're
actually actually flight at this point
unfortunately I really would have gotten
ugly I definitely agree with that which
I think why didn't I start taking yeah
you probably you probably just take here
yep
and it's now forward b5 all right that's
about again four pawns to my five or
your five excuse me I've got the two
routes and a knight and a bishop
so definitely I'd have been a
interesting battle we've played some
good points in game since then so a
little better yeah still working on it
that's how that's how we learn we have
to go over the games to see how we're
doing with them
I'm still chapter 1 page 2 so well thank
you for watching our show please like
share and subscribe and we'll see you
next time
[Music]